For this question, you're asked to define two procedures.
The first one takes a match as its inputs along with a replacement,
and it outputs some sort of structure, which you'll be able to use.
In the second procedure, apply converter, which will change a string according
to the match and replacement.
I'll just do an example.
aaabaa--if this is our match and replacement, the aba will be replaced with b.
The next string we'll have will be aaba.
Then we've got aba again, so we'll replace that with b.
There are no more matches, so we stop.
You can see at each step it's changed, and when we change it no more, we stop.
What our code is going to do is continue.
As long as we've made a replacement at the previous step, we'll do a step again.
If we haven't made a replacement, then we'll stop.
On to the code.
What structure do I want?
Well, I'm simply going to make a list where the first entry in the list is the match,
and the second entry is the replacement.
Apply_converter has as its input a converter which we made in make_converter.
That's a list, and the string that we want to change.
I said that I was going to continue changing the string as long as the string
was not the same as it was before.
We're going to have to keep track of the previous string.
At the start there isn't a previous string.
While previous is not the same as the current string, I want to carry on with the loop.
As soon as I enter the loop, I want previous to be equal to string,
and then I want to look for the match in the string.
The position of the math we can find using find,
and we're looking for the first word in the converter.
If we find it, then we're going to replace our string with a new string,
which is the first part of the string up to the position, not excluding it--
the start position of our match.
We replace that with the replacement, and finally we want to concatenate
the part of the string after the match.
We find it's position by starting at the beginning of the match
and adding on the length of the match.
Then taking that to the end of the string.
As long as we've made a change, the loop continues.
If we haven't made a change, the loop ends, and we return the string.